you can see how light and fluffy this
material is trash sorted shredded and
piled into heaps
but when United Airlines looks at this
garbage it sees jet fuel or more
specifically sustainable aviation fuel
known as saf which many see as the key
to decarbonizing Aviation but there's a
supply problem producers made about 15.8
million gallons of sap last year in the
U.S major U.S airlines used about 17.5
billion gallons of jet fuel
we don't have the solution commercially
available at scale to really make a
difference right now but we do know what
that solution is and it's sustainable
aviation fuel so Airlines and the
government are now pumping money into
the low carbon fuel sector investing
millions in projects like sap produced
from trash to get this nascent industry
off the ground but will it take off
the aviation industry alone accounted
for more than two percent of global
emissions in 2021 and its share of the
pie is expected to grow unlike the Auto
industry which is moving away from
fossil fuels to battery power commercial
Jets still need liquid fuel to fly
if you look at our greenhouse gas
footprint as an airline a commercial
airline 98 of the emissions that we
create and put into the atmosphere are
from the use of fuel saf is what's
called a drop-in solution because it can
drop in in place of petroleum fuel it
doesn't require new infrastructure or
even new planes the saf on the market
today can cut emissions by up to 80
percent compared to Conventional jet
fuel
in Sparks Nevada fulcrum bioenergy is
working on a fuel with a bigger promise
we produce a fuel product that has zero
net impact on carbon emissions it starts
with trash about 350 000 tons of it each
year
after sorting out things like rocks and
metals the leftover garbage is made into
that confetti-like material there's
paper there's wrappings there's plastic
shreddings it's the feedstock for
fulcrum's fuel all of this material what
you're seeing in this Warehouse here
we'll convert into about a hundred
thousand gallons of Transportation fuel
but getting from this to fuel isn't
simple creating that feedstock is the
first part of the process the next stage
of the process is what you see here
taking that feedstock with the white
conveyors going up to the top of this
first gasification Tower beginning the
process of transforming that feedstock
into usable gases it's a three-stage
gasification process what you're looking
at here is the first stage
the process creates carbon monoxide and
hydrogen molecules known as thin gas
which is then cleaned and sent through
this Fisher Trope system but here those
gases are actually converted into a
liquid Transportation fuel that can be
sold to refineries or ultimately will be
you know modifying and we're upgrading
into jet fuel fulcrum opened this
facility its first commercial scale
plant last year and it says it will
produce 11 million gallons of its
synthetic crude oil product here by next
year
United Cathay Pacific Japan Airlines and
others have already signed off take
agreements with fulcrum that could see
the company delivered 290 million
gallons of its fuel annually it really
is all about Supply I mean let's let's
call it what it is there's not a lack of
demand for low carbon sap which is why
outside of fulcrum's Nevada plant 25
staff production refineries are now
planned or open in the U.S alone
United is already pumping a blend of jet
fuel and staff onto its flights here out
of Los Angeles as well as San Francisco
and Amsterdam airports
in 2022 it used 3 million gallons of sap
this year it expects that to hit 10
million but United has a goal of net
zero emissions by 2050. overall I need 4
billion gallons of fuel so if we're
talking about 10 million gallons of saff
it is far less than 0.1 percent of my
total fuel supply which is really where
we get to the the Crux of the issue how
do we generate more production how do we
create more Supply so that it's not less
than 0.1 percent of my fuel earlier this
year the airline launched a more than
100 million dollar fund to invest in
startups looking for new ways to produce
sap from feedstocks including alcohol
Forest waste and of course trash it even
enlisted Oscar the Grouch to draw
attention to the effort trash like this
could be used for good if sap is going
to make its way into the market on a
more broad-based more commonly used
approach it's going to have to be new
feedstock sources that unleash larger
volumes
the South being pumped today relies on
used cooking oil and animal fats as its
feedstock vegetable oils fats waste oils
greases are also used for fuels for the
on road Transportation sector so the
same feedstocks are used for biodiesel
and renewable diesel so there's
competition about 6 million metric tons
of used cooking oil and 27 million
metric tons of animal fats are traded
globally every year which would cover
only around five percent of jet fuel
consumption there is not enough to use
cooking oil in the world to fuel
Aviation that is true but when you start
looking at the second generation around
trash around residue from the forest
from ethanol we have 17 billion gallons
of ethanol in the U.S alone there is
plenty of feedstock there it's a
question of how do you get the feedstock
to the right production location so that
you can actually create sustainable
Aviation fuels with a low carbon
footprint at least 30 Airlines have
promised to use sap usually for 10
percent of their fuel consumption by
2030 and the Biden Administration has
set a goal of scaling U.S sap production
to 3 billion gallons per year by then
too s p Global projections show the
country won't quite hit that but it will
scale to more than 2 billion gallons a
year by the Target date we certainly see
the framework and we'd certainly see the
corporate Community taking steps in
order to increase domestic sap
production and so even if mandates are
not being AT
progress is certainly being made then
there's the issue of cost saf is
typically two to four times more
expensive than regular fuel Airlines
have tight margins
and customers are always looking for the
best price and it's uncertain how much
tolerance consumers have for increased
prices by using violence the inflation
reduction act set aside about 300
million dollars for low emissions
Aviation Technologies plus 500 million
dollars for biofuels it also established
two separate tax credits for saf to help
bring its cost per gallon closer to
Conventional fuel
the IRA was
it actually put sustainable Aviation
fuels on the map this was really a
signal to the market to producers that
the government is committed to building
a market for sustainable Aviation fuels
and it is backing this as the pathway to
decarbonize Aviation and while experts
say more incentives are also needed the
industry is now flying with some wind at
its back sap is having a moment and that
moment is going to continue for a very
long time
[Music]